well I think it's search engines and ad
networks and there's all sorts of ways
to connect to people as individuals and
and what I think we're going to find is
that we're more of a market maker where
we're trying to find a bit in and ask to
communicate with any person at any point
in time that market will clear on the
value of that person as well as the
value of the product so I think in many
ways we're going to be more like other
transparent markets whether those be
equities markets or bond markets or real
estate markets and that's actually a
good thing because I think that
transparency is going to create better
economic rigour around making sure that
advertising really works and that people
will spend more on the things that work
and less some of the things that don't
work once you've done that once you've
done that matching of people in message
then you're still going to have great
creativity to try to capture people's
imagination their hopes and aspirations
and it'd be a valid part of their
community